hundreds of civilian men and teenage
boys were massacred by eritrean soldiers
in the ethiopian town of aksum in
november last year
according to rights groups amnesty
international released videos
which it says were verified by dozens of
testimonies
including this one of one of the victims
ethiopian and eritrean forces were
pursuing the tigrayan people's
liberation front or tplf
who'd previously controlled ethiopia for
most of three decades
ethiopia's attorney general has said the
people killed in aksum were
in fact combatants
it is established that the great
majority of those killed in this
incident were members of the fighting
force of the tplf
who engaged the eritrean forces though
they were not in uniform
these forces later went back to the city
and attacked civilians in the streets
according to our investigation 93
individuals were killed due to fighting
the government's report contradicts not
just amnesty's report
but also the findings of human rights
watch and the government's own human
rights commission
funds are to be in stark contrast to
what we have found
because uh from our findings
uh we have seen that most of them were
civilians
and the patriarchs
conducted house to house raids uh
to pull out some male members of
the families they found and kill them
in front of their family members
axams isn't the only massacre here
relatives mourn protesters who were
reportedly shot by eritrean soldiers
in the town of wucrow in february
thousands of civilians have been killed
in the conflict
eritrea denies its soldiers have
committed abuses
ethiopia says it's open to independent
investigations
elections are due next month and
ethiopia's prime minister abby ahmed
wants to stay in office some opposition
and observers say there's no chance of a
free and fair poll
interethnic violence in some regions and
the war in tigre
will mean many can't vote since the
conflict began six months ago
media access has been heavily restricted
but reports of rapes and massacres
keep coming this is one of several
videos
circulated on social media of what
appears to be ethiopian soldiers
executing at least 11 unarmed men and
throwing their bodies over a cliff
researchers and journalists verified it
last month
the government dismissed their claims
rights groups say the un
and the african union have done too
little too late
to try and stop the atrocities malcolm
webb
al jazeera